the resolution before us today is about
protecting our democracy
it isn't about protecting the integrity
of this body it's bigger than the census
I testified myself for almost seven
hours before this very committee this is
just more political theater well the
house just voted to hold the Secretary
of Commerce and the Attorney General in
criminal contempt this after the
Attorney General bar and Secretary Ross
wrote a letter sent a letter to House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi saying we regret
that the committee continues to
recommend the house wield its criminal
contempt authority even though we remain
willing to work toward an appropriate
accommodation by taking this action the
houses both unnecessarily undermining
interbranch comedy and degrading the
constitutional separation of powers and
its own institutional integrity there is
no information to hide there is no
institutional integrity to preserve
accordingly we urge the house postpone
the contempt vote they didn't they move
forward let's bring in our panel matthew
cottan Ettie editor-in-chief of the
washington free beacon jonathan swan
national political reporter for Axios
and Jason Riley Wall Street Journal
columnist senior fellow at the Manhattan
Institute a lot of breaking news guys
we'll start there with the contempt
Matthew I'm reminded of that moment
earlier this year when Attorney General
Barr met Nancy Pelosi at an event on
Capitol Hill and asked her did you bring
your handcuffs there's such a theatrical
aspect to all of this it's it's a closed
easy way of kind of throwing Chum to her
left-wing base and dragging them along
in order to prevent them from just going
whole hog for impeachment but I have to
say if you're a voter an American voter
and paying attention to what's happening
in the House today you're going to say
why aren't they actually addressing
kitchen table issues I mean you need a
whiteboard for all that was happening on
Capitol Hill today as far as the votes
John on the criminal contempt question a
bold prediction that the bill bar
Justice Department is not going to
prosecute bill Barr just a crazy
prediction this is really all about
impeachment and
there are a number of Democrats now who
believe that the only way to hold the
president accountable is to open an
impeachment inquiry and to do that to do
all the investigations channeled through
that and I think it's really striking
today that the this is such small ball
for a lot of these members and actually
what it does is it drives the
frustration levels up even further among
the progressive flank every time these
incremental actions happen this is not
satisfying them you know Matthew will
say oh there's just our enchantment and
that's what it is
but the Chum is not satisfying the
people whom the Chum is mental is meant
for to satisfy so we're you're
mentioning impeachment the effort to
bring up articles of impeachment today
failed in the house the president
reacting to that on Twitter as he often
does just moments ago the United States
House of Representatives has just
overwhelmingly voted to kill the
resolution on impeachment 332 95 to 1
this perhaps the most ridiculous and
time-consuming project I have ever had
to work on impeachment of your president
who has led the greatest economic boom
in the history of our country the best
jobs numbers biggest tax reduction
rebuilt military and much more is now
over this should never be allowed to
happen to another president of the
United States again Jason he seems to be
relishing this this kind of fight that
has developed oh sure he's certainly
relishing it it's dividing the
opposition which is always good for the
incumbent but Nancy Pelosi is in a
dilemma here
she has moderates in her caucus they
don't want to be back home campaigning
on on this next year
she doesn't think it'll help Democrats
next year in the election so she's
trying to hold that off but she has this
progressive wing that wants to go there
and that's that's her dilemma right now
but all of these subpoenas and contempt
citations this is ankle-biting on the
part of Democrats they won't really pull
the trigger here with impeachment at
least not yet and this is what they're
doing in the meantime when Republicans
controlled the house they cited Eric
Holder and it had absolutely no impact I
mean this
next week next week we're going to have
we think the Muller testimony on
Wednesday at least this we think it's
going to happen today you had the SDN Y
or say that essentially the case on
campaign finances or where we don't know
if and the indictments will come later
but there's no indictments now so it's
like where's the beef well there's a
really important point on that to
underline which is that these articles
that the article impeachment drafted by
representative Al Green there is no
mention nothing like it is purely based
on the president's what he describes as
the president's racism so and here's
something that's really important this
is not some little fringe this is not a
small little progressive wing 95
Democrats voted to consider that and
that is just on those narrow grounds
well alone everything else obstruction
or any of the rest of